so i i'm assuming it's going to be
different but what is the process like
in
voice acting in japan for auditioning um
for auditions
uh will the auditions come to your
agency and then the agency will um pick
someone that's suitable for the role and
they'll be like um there's like
uh two stages there's like tape audition
and there's a studio audition
um and tape audition is where you just
send your voice into the people who make
the anime
and um stage audition is when they when
you actually go in front of all the the
directors and like the people who make
the anime
if that means yeah so how many people
will be there normally
uh depends on like the anime but
um i don't know like sometimes there's
like only like twenty
five twenty like five ten twenty only
twenty
what sometimes there's like more there's
like yeah
wait this is this is the stuff right
yeah yeah yeah yeah twenty staff members
oh no no oh you mean
but sometimes like there's like around
usually there's around five
people but sometimes they could be like
10 or like maybe even more
wow like judging and like judging it wow
and then
there's about 20 to 30 auditioning uh
yeah for one character or
yeah sometimes for one character like
sometimes um
the anime like people they'll take like
a whole day auditioning like several
characters
and um like this was like pre-covered
yeah yeah yeah yeah but um yeah they'll
be like
you know they'll always be like people
waiting in the waiting room
and then oh god you're all like oh yeah
you go to the park
before you walk
because they're holding the scripts
right and they're kind of like
practicing in there
is it like big tension in the room yeah
there is it's like it's like super quiet
oh that's so nerve-wracking and you see
someone holding the same script as you
are and you're like
you know because there's like people at
movies like i'm gonna like people turn
out really cocky is there anyone ever
like that who's like
i've got this go home ah no because you
know like even
even like the really like famous voice
actors they auditioned to get like
the same like the roles that's right you
might turn up and they might be like a
triple a like
yeah oh my god that's terrifying but the
good thing about this job is that it's
not always
them that get the job right it's like
the person who suits the voice
like the character best so yeah it is
really nerve-wracking though when
they're like in front of you and they're
like practicing their script and you're
like
oh wait so you've been in a situation
where you were in like auditioning for
the same role as a massive
voice
you know and it's like it's so
nerve-wracking just to like act in front
of like all the staff members making the
anime
and then there's like this huge like you
know someone you've known
like since like ages ago and yeah you're
probably a fan of yeah
yeah like who's like you've had like
posters of them up on your room or
something like that right yeah so
yeah it's like really nerve-wracking and
yeah that's like so different from how
they do it in like the
english anime because because they when
they're dubbed they have to be dubbed
like pretty fast
right so they can't like they never hold
open auditions it's been
it's been a very very long time i think
they'll be like hey
we we know that you're good at what you
do trying for this character you should
record
an audio clip and send it in and that's
it there's no like
another one sometimes there is but it
really depends on the thing
but it's really fast and it's that's why
there's normally like less actors i
guess compared to japan because
it's normally you have to be kind of
established to get a chance it's kind of
difficult
yeah wow how many auditions do you have
to go through or like for different
series before you normally land like a
single role um
uh well in the industry they say like
auditions
like it's like like it's like normal to
like
not pass an audition so like they say
like if you like
take 50 auditions if you get into one
then that's like
like you're you're still on the good
side like
like 40 to 1. yeah yeah yeah i suppose
if you're
like competing against 20 other voice
actresses yeah you know some people
spend all day
from their home just on like voices.com
sending in like [ __ ] hundreds
right drives me insane and yeah it's
really like
um like because like you know when you
get the audition you want to know more
about the character
and yeah you want to know more about the
um the manga or like you know whatever
it's based on so
like you you read all these manga and
like you know you take your time like
you know
understanding the character and stuff
like that and so yeah it's like
you know when you don't pass it's like
oh i didn't like yes sometimes i
get too invested because i feel that if
i read the manga and i feel like i know
this character i can do it why didn't i
get it yeah
and then you gotta go to the next one
it's like yeah it must be quite
difficult too yeah
how do you kind of keep that detachment
level there well
at first i was like i felt really like
down when i didn't pass
yeah but then now it's kind of like like
you know you need to
take like you just keep like dropping
like you know
not understandable yeah yeah yeah yeah
you just you just gotta like you
grow thick skin i suppose yeah yeah and
just like it's nothing personal right
yeah nothing personal kid